une production du studio sf bio sans fil
de la bad castres on parle de ce qu'on
veut nous inviter d'attiches ph quand
avec moi dôme plantes sur votre podcast
ou une idée de podcasts en conception
que voulait amener un haut niveau vous
pouvez louer le studio sfr ou est-ce
qu'on est ici on a tout le matériel pour
vous on a la technique on s'occupe de
tout vous n'avez qu'à penser à votre
contenu
si vous voulez plus d'informations à ce
sujet là vous pouvez nous écrire au sans
filtre podcast à commercial gmail.com
cette semaine d'hommes cette semaine on
a reçu une légende de l'humour c'est
vraiment un honneur de s'entretenir avec
lui c'est michel courtemanche que connu
un succès mondial le succès incroyable
dans sa carrière puis qui est décidé à
mener de prendre un petit peu de recul
sur cette industrie l'ubs sur la scène
pour se consacrer à d'autres projets
nous a vraiment parlé en détail de tout
ce processus l'oppidum peu plus sombre
que vécue nous raconter des anecdotes
vraiment super intéressante qu'ils
rencontrent et 1 6 2 jim carrey une
super belle rencontre et s mais juste
avant l'alliance et raconte là on va en
profiter pour remercier nos annonceurs
sans qui rien de tout ce serait possible
le poids de gaz de cette semaine et
présenté par communauto comme une auto
c'est un service d'auto partage depuis
le début de la pandémie est années qu'on
travaille chez nous mais j'ai réalisé
que ma voiture à rester parquet 90% du
temps je n'utilise pratiquement pas je
fais pas de kilométrage dessus mais je
la paye comme si j'utilisais à tous les
jours comme note aussi un service qui
est flexible qui répondent à vos besoins
et fait comment ça fonctionne en fait
c'est que vous donne aux de
l'application puis vous pouvez réserver
votre voiture comme on réserve un hôtel
seulement qu'à vous en avez besoin pour
planifier vos voyages 30 jours à l'avant
si vous savez vous avez besoin d'aller
par exemple à québec
ou bien vous pouvez faire de cette
dernière minute si vous avez besoin
d'aller au clash copie certains allaient
acheter 10 régler sans peau au costco
floués cette dernière minute les frais
de communauto en fait tu comprennes
l'essence comprennent l'entretien
comprennent les assurances vous n'avez
même pas besoin de penser à ce ni de
payer pour ça quand vous utilisez pas la
voiture puis à plus de 2000 voitures
amoria y en a un dans le parking du
studio fait que c'est ultra pratique
ultra accessible pour tout le monde
communauto cette entreprise 100% le call
avec une dimension sociale une dimension
urbanistique parce que ça réduit le
nombre de voitures sur les routes
vraiment considérable mans des
statistiques ici l'autopartage par
personne une voiture en autopartage ces
dix voitures de moins sur la route est
aussi une entreprise qui a une dimension
environnementale parce que bien sûr
l'autopartage ça diminue les gaz à effet
de serre c'est 1,2 tonne d réduction par
personne par année de gaz à effet de
serre ces massifs
c'est vraiment énorme donc si vous
voulez faire une différence sur votre
environnement
communauto est vraiment une super bonne
il ya ce fait calédonie l'application
puis merci beaucoup à communauto
d'encourager le sans filtre le podcast
aujourd'hui est présenté par chambre
quitte l'entreprise québécoise pionnière
dans l'industrie du champ de l'huile de
chanvre depuis plus de 15 ans ils font
des produits pour le corps des produits
naturels les produits qui font du bien
et pourquoi l'huile de chambre c'est
parce que ça décuple toutes les
bienfaits et les ingrédients a fait avec
lesquels ils interagissent
ils ont 21 produits révolutionnaires ph
on a essayé essayé un d'entre eux est
est ce moi j'ai la chance de ces leur
crème musculaire en fait je me suis
blessé à la course à pied vélo une coupe
deux semaines plus j'ai commencé de la
réhabilitation un physio mais aussi à
mme appliquer de la crème jusqu'alors de
chance à tous les soirs puis grâce à
l'huile de chanvre en fait l'art nikkei
les autres huiles essentielles pénètre
bien dans la peau puis sans relâche les
muses pauvres et à place de mettre
n'importe quel secret sur vos muscles
puis pas vraiment sentir la différence
chambre la craie musculaire de chance
fonctionne réellement puis moi ça m'a
permis de détendre les muscles c'est bon
pour les douleurs chroniques ces bons
produits les douleurs musculaires quand
vous être réac et c'est bon pour tout
seul c'est 100% naturel fait que moi je
le recommande grandement en tout cas mon
expérience était 100% positifs qui ont
un code promo pour vous qui est sans
filtre 25 pour 25 % de rabais sur tous
les produits sur leur site web change
pour un coût donc ch à 1,9 point qu'au
fait caler les encourager des produits
100% naturels qui marche pour de vrai
fait que mercy la gagne 2 chante let's
go le podcast de cette semaine et
présenté par nos amis chez mindscape
vous les connaissez on en parle souvent
mais on continue à en parler parce que
c'est un coup de coeur pour nous autres
c'est la compagnie par excellence pour
l'entretien sous la ceinture mais aussi
pour l'entretien des hommes en général
si vous n'avez pas encore essayé le
lendemain 3.0 vous dormez sous une roche
que ce soit pour vous pour votre
partenaire
c'est l'instrument de cruising par
excellence il coule de céramique ci qui
empêche de vous [ __ ] les boys sewall
trouve ça se fait dans douche
nous autres jamais de poils qui traînent
sur le plancher de la scène et c'est
toujours dans douche
toujours dans douche fait le préfet
clermont 3-0 vient avec le perfect
package 3.0 qui est une terre de rang du
tourneur pour boss des boxeurs ample
aller boxer comme gordon est aussi sa
parfums le les parfums
mindscape que les perches porte
maintenant mais c'est mon coup de coeur
pur celui qui porte sur 6 à 110 ans a
emmené sa soeur dans la partie ça ça
vient réveiller des émotions 10 choses
que je ne soupçonnais même pas en moi je
me lève le matin je sens au pis je le
vois sous un nouvel angle
ph et puis kim est ce vraiment ça a tout
changé de toujours le soleil qui brille
derrière moi maintenant
vrai
un pays si ces pertes ne portait pas de
juger c'est sûr que je le mettrais mais
le jeu en vaut la belle copie qui fait
que je ne mets pas mais ça sent vraiment
bon on a un code promo pour vous autres
en fait qu'ils aient le sens filtre en
un mot 20% de rabais
la livraison gratuite mais pour
s'engager la livraison gadjo ville
d'homs que je vous le donne fait qu'il
remercie la gamecube entre pia courez
vous achetez sur
[Musique]
michel sait pas plaisir de traces avant
[Rires]
de savoir
je viens pas de gaz
juste pour me ressource émissions dans
le miroir une entrevue avec moi c'est ça
c'est jean alain qui m'avait écrit pour
dire que que tu l'entrée de la plate
forme puisque ma tv pointé hier c'est ça
on avoir parlé en long et en large sur
puis la même journée en fait moi j'ai
reçu ce message là je continuerai ma
journée plus ma mère mes cris plat dit
hey vous receviez quelques revanche au
podcast bien lancer sa plateforme qui
mois et ayant grandi dans les années 90
jeux d'été sketch c'est une nouvelle
fois que je me rappelle de mon enfance
le tir sans que ça myhabit et tuer toute
mon adolescence et tout mais je me
rappelle très bien de mon contact avec
toi python nord puis puis j'ai arrêté
les années 80 81 14 ha ouais nan 14
194,5 j'imagine que chez nous' télé
c'était les vhs de tes performances en
fait seulement voilà le vieux take it
off
il ya maintes est une version à roues
l'autriche pour ce mais oui j'avais hs
après ça a été mis en dvd
sato fait un boutre mais ya pas eu de
réduction quelle équipe du rift
allemands s'attendent à 14 puis les
débuts c'était marqué l'année dans le
fond c'est vrai que maintenant cette
période là de 200 puis de spect'art sa
partie à 80 semi-professionnels le smic
raquin et j'ai pu dire dans le milieu et
sur les côtés je les fêtes de mai
officiellement officiellement que j'ai
commencé avec les monstres du mot 86 et
puis j'ai arrêté en tournant un film
médiocre justement oui médium en france
en 96
c'est la dernière fois que j'ai fait la
bo en france et puis après son
accouchement revenant montréal j'avais
arrêté les spectacles les plus question
que le chasseur de scène je tenais façon
je la réalisation et ggt plie comme
comédienne série britannique où j'ai
joué en anglais par un dit mot je prends
des cours d'anglais pour le ronde pour
le temps qu'est né à 28 go bailly
voulait quelqu'un avec un gros accent
voyez la nature
elle et puis j'ai tourné ça qu'on a dit
moi pas perso mon dieu j'ai rien foutu
par un petit but sauf peut-être lever le
coude élevé la narine et puis wifi et et
bon partant d intox pas manqué que
quelques semaines ensuite bon
aujourd'hui ses 22 ans je consomme plus
mais entre ça j'ai démarré une compagnie
de production télé que j'ai vendu un mât
qui fonctionnent trop
ensuite j'ai fait beaucoup ben des
affaires de mise en scène écrire des
spectacles phares du coaching au soleil
avoir des digues coutu à 35 de clown
c'est ce droit exactement qu'est ce qui
se passe dans un coaching de clown ben
en fait moi ce que je faisais c'était de
vérifier si physiquement il était apte à
faire ce job là même s'il y en a trop
longtemps qu'il faisait bon niveau des
mouvements s'était pas tout à fait sur
moi j'essayais de leur apprendre la
technique que j'utilisais bataille
difficile à transmettre c'est pas
difficile à transmettre
même si difficile à apprendre si tullow
pour martin c'est comme quelqu'un qui
sait pas danser le breakdance le sound
of silver lotto bruit mondiale 6-0 gêne
le ministre reçoit ses techniques de
break dans mon physique en général tout
est tout ce qui était formée mais
tendent à cette tradition le du mime du
clown ou te tue le cri dans l'ombre et
moi j'écris vous regardez c'est même mon
propre style mais en copiant sur un
modèle de données bien sûr de là mais
note que j'ai compris que tout était
basé sur le prends le principe d'une
vague de
quiconque comme les bons tout est basé
là dessus du point d'impact entre amis
ton premier point d'impact et le dernier
point d'impact à bouger cette étude très
poussée
1 école [ __ ] avoir vos bougeant
dernier c'est la tête en premier les
époux vont suivre ça dépend à quel point
d'impact puisqu'elle quelle partie du
corps va réagir en dernier mettant cette
horloge justement pis toutes les
subtilités du mouvement tu l'as pris par
toi même avoir une expérimentation des
enfants tout jeune j'avais vu claude
saint denis et qui est un même très très
populaire à l'époque faire un spectacle
au sens la nature et puis ça m'a fasciné
et puis en prenant la maison j'ai comme
essayer de recréer ce que j'avais vu
devant le miroir boîte 6 puis j'ai
découvert très jeune vers l'âge de 10
ans que j'ai j'avais cette possibilité
lolë de faim à croire aux gens que j'ai
été soit en arrière d'un mur ou d'ouvrir
une fenêtre où il y avait du verre
direct une petite affaire classique
classe et je faisais vous fait rire tout
seul et comme je le faisais way pour
faire rimer jam à l'école plus tard à
polyvalente legault y avait une voiture
avec un toi tu es mais habituellement il
ya des fenêtres à toi tu es ou à bastia
qui comme une corvette de [ __ ] pas des
fantômes dont on doit non non non non
non pas fait de 10 hors du champ il ya
deux buts étaient partis mais lui était
jolie quand même pas la tp a gardé son
champ privé afin de son champion j'ai
fait comme si j'allais finir l on les
regardait
c'est le premier prime offerte
j'avais peur mais celle de saint louis à
la petite école pour amuser les amis
parce que quand cinquième année je me
rappelle mon professeur dominique et
rebbie montre où ma rapide son nom lui
il y avait compris que je te pas normal
il faisait bon chaque vendredi au quai
30 à damien avant la classe jusque to
you go to stay femme un peu ton début de
semaine ce sont ces sofac pas c'était
une façon de canaliser mon énergie c'est
parce que je sais pas mais je t'ai
turbulente j'ai fait connaître un petit
10 euros ht dans le rouge une oie c'est
sûr j'aurais dit oui et je faisais les
spectacles à la fin à la fin de la
semaine puis je toujours reste un peu le
fait rire les collègues de d'école tout
c'est à ce moment là que ces spectacles
tripes et c'est quelqu'un qui elle
calmement devant la classe
ben j'étais nerveux parce que je savais
pas ce que j'allais faire mais j'ai
improvisé une parodie d'une bouée un
sketch que j'avais vu sur la
récupération
l'échantillonnage kiss & kill espèce de
l'espèce de pantin désarticulé 2
du personnage de metz qui s'est formée
dans ces années là est-ce que c'est
surtout formée en impro ouais quand j'ai
commencé à faire de l'impro cégep
montmorency avec claude legault martin
paix civile et ça c'est là que j'ai
vraiment évolué dans ce top model de
communes d'île de france la comédie
physique parce qu'un et proto portes des
quarts entre pas de costumes ça que je
voulais me mirent que j'arrive à en
charge
je te capable peut-être de mieux le fait
que les os donc c'est là que j g comme
fait évoluer sur cette technique là
puisqu'à ce moment là tu avais des
t'avais des personnages clés que tu
incarnes et c'est ce que tu en avais
auquel survenait le tir parce qu'on
pense à ton neuf on attire des
classiques qui nous viennent comme
l'haltérophile ou le drummer outil légal
fort ces choses-là on y penser mais tout
est ce que tu avais se met en quatre ans
dont un prouesse que des fautes retomber
dans royal ans qui revenait tout le
temps ça peut que j'appelle tous pidoux
le dis tout le temps salar aghili fait
c'était juste le tc celui maintenant je
vous avais vus à des extraits spectacle
c'est lui qui va dans machine un
photomaton ces toupies doogie volant
tout pidoux qui fait une autre fois puis
même que dans d'autres personnages
mettons mon américain au western où le
russe y revenait défaut donc c'est un
personnage qui te passe partout un peu
le qui m'aidait beaucoup quand même pas
se poser la question si catete jeunes
parce que tu mets ton ce qui tendrait
savent tic est une très grande carrière
par une période en titane et de décider
d'arrêter
et quand tu es petit tu faisais des
titres et messieurs puis quand est ce
que le switch s'est fait que commencer à
ne plus vouloir faire ceux où est le
plaisir était plus dans le faire pour
toi dans le miroir développer ton même
piqué la finalité c'est pas
nécessairement par un spectacle explique
moi ce que je voulais faire dans la vie
c'est très attend le bus admettait seul
but jamais jamais jamais si le soc a
maintenant la réalisation battant nul
mais ça a été en marge d'une table à
dessin tout s'est tu es déçu et à la et
puis je savais pas trop quoi faire dans
la vie mais ça à force d'en parler avec
les autres je sais pas quoi faire
aujourd'hui graphiste une vraie job
épuisant
je pensais écrire un fou le nom une mine
énième un des leurs à l'époque
non si ça me tentait pas ben laden en
est jamais tentée cet appel ben c'est un
peu prétentieux je vous dirais je suis
tellement drôle que je vois lille prouvé
sur scène à des milliers de personnes en
même temps
c'est justement donc il faut que tout le
monde le sache et un drôle de cadeau le
concept trouve le fait rire les gens
c'est le fun mais écrire un show partir
en tournée puis tout perdre non
seulement les moins alors ça m'attirait
pas par axor je n'en mange les fêtes par
défaut je rentrais d'un monde les mauves
après ça je me suis retrouvé seul parti
je fait cavalier seul parent six ans
alors ce qui ce qui faisait que ça me
tente un moins pour répondre à ta
question c'est que quand tu aimes pose
que tu fais watsco sais pas ce que
j'aime ce que je fais mais je fais parce
que j'aime ça c'était ça le problème
avec moi comme je le têt réalisateur ben
lui mot pour moi c'était posta correct
mais je sais pas soufflé france et je
savais que je m'en allais lentement vers
la réalisation que ça le fid poème est
ce que tu fais c'est que pour faire ce
qui est m6 et sa star wars
parce que ça devienne job que le total
job vous préférez du monde peu importe
comment ça paie pas c'était malade si tu
es quelqu'un est mort c'est quelqu'un
t'a fait crisser le outils le report
show must go s'est dissous qui compte
alors à la fin justin h mais c'est un
peu comme un guichet automatique moment
il manque pas sa canne puis tout
l'entourage en prennent pas batley ou
une grosse partie alors non pour toutes
ces raisons le chanter trop de pression
le rétro le monde travaillait pour moi
pillain ya un bureau petit à petit sa
coupable d'avoir lydie des peut-être me
torcher tapalpa personnes bien mais il
ya un moment donné c'était pu s'était
plus rendu de faire rire les gens dans
mon discours est beaucoup plus gros que
ce terrain d'une jobs way s'ils se
rendent une job banal où il ya dix fois
l'oeuvre faisait du mérou charest nazis
bon truc m'a démangé un paquet montre
que je suis une quel état d'un
crissement ce type
voyons le tube ndi cristini c'est savez
sans doute la plus haute automatique
toulon à 250 chevaux
c'est tellement d'obstacles c'est
tellement des chaumes ça aucun sens x
factor c'était ça donne à 100% à chaque
fois pour que oui parce que sinon les
gens et voit qu'il se passe quelque
chose
ça doit être un paradoxe
d'ici là portait de casque était
clairement comme un talent pur c'est
clairement comme un talent pour la scène
tu as un talent pour faire rire le monde
juste des petites arrivé ici on en rit
petit un talent pour la mimique c'est
indéniable mais d'avoir ce talent à la
maison et mes seins devons jongler que
ce taux monte et il était tellement bon
là-dedans d'ananas pee wee mais j'aime
pas ce qui obligeait pas quelque chose
que j'aime pas juste parce que je suis
bon c'est bien c'est pas la job que tout
le monde veut l'autre et la job des as
sikkah thème les jeunes ne jalouse aime
beaucoup le vip étaient parties quand
j'ai tous les rushes ils sont déjà
complets
il y en avait sur les olas ton dos ou
ainsi un autre âge mais il ya aussi les
aussi la fête j'avais cette maladie
mentale l'autre n'a pas encore déclaré
kiki mais qui me hantaient lavige alaric
je voyais que je t'ai pas heureux je me
demandais vraiment pourquoi parce que
tout le monde me disait que j'avais tout
mais oui c'est quand tu as tout pas le
droit exact parce que c'est une place
c'est justement le succès qu'ils étaient
connus ici en france c'est une place qui
est que bien des gens ce milieu je
rêverais d'avoir puis vous de voir mais
qui sont tellement loin de comprennent
la clau
exactement un truc je peux pas croire
qui est qui qui s'envole de tout mais
c'est la personne des points en route
heureusement pour vouloir alors que
cette personne jour bosch et paul n'y a
pas un montant d'argent qui va enfin que
qu'il soit heureux c'est impossible
puis aujourd'hui quand je repense à
cette période là est-ce que tu une
certaine nostalgie autour ou pas tout
je pense souvent moi c'est les gens qui
me le rappelle soins
moi j'ai tourné la page fait longtemps
mais des fois tu sais je vous reçois
voir un facebook d'un gars de
l'ouzbékistan vu mes cassettes temps
était petit but devenu que bombay l'inde
la russie le ticket dimitri payet moi je
suis clown pas très doué justement ce
matin la planète m'écrivent qui me
disent que je te jette une source
d'inspiration pour les autres mais sur
les autres mais leur appel j'ai fait ce
que j'avais à faire du mieux que je
pensais que je pouvais le faire si
j'allais passer un impact jamais passé
je faisais puis quand mettons durant
cette période là tu sais on peut
regarder des entrevues de toile dans
lesquels tu es tu encore un peu ce
personnage là encore un peu le
personnage exubérant puis un peu fou
est-ce que c'était quelque chose qui
consciemment tu faisais où c'était juste
la personne qui était dans cette espèce
de d'instabilité de doute de carrière
plaisait moyens piqué tutut incarnait
tout de tuer entrevue télé jean joulin
exemple exemple avec l entrevue et qui
savent trop sur youtube pour les gens
qui nous écoutent s'ils veulent voir
cela avec gregory charles
oui oui ce tarif il ya comme la musique
qu'à tout moment tu te relèves le crash
de l'eau partout il ya des personnes
comprend ce qui se passe avec toi tu
sais quand le type comme leur l'orang
outan qu'apporte t il le faire de la
promo pour un show aux banques sa marque
la montée
moi je me suis toujours arrangé pour
faire des affaires
pas normal la tic comme je donne l
impression de 1 mulhouse signé le triplé
trop de drogues ce type chaud partout
mais j'avais des meilleurs commentaires
sur ces entrevues look temps je faisais
des numéros à juste pour rire
ouais alors
puis souvent ce sera marrant c'est dans
les best-of puissance et un peu comment
je te dirai ce théâtre outremont secret
c'est à dire que quand je pense à une
émission je m'arrangeais pour ce soit
tellement le bordel que tout le monde
parle de la contrôler maintenant
alimentaire les camps amende surtout
boudreau que ça ça passe à des vestes ou
c'était de la promo gratuite
c'était la même chose avec les espoirs
et un après dans les best of c'est comme
ce que les gens qui est aussi l'occasion
est ce qu il al matari de connivence ne
peut pas tout en portant tous le berne
de teck larman connivence ben souvent
c'était d'aider des musiciens que je
connaissais à qui je me rappelle avoir
croisé souvent migaud scott price c'est
de l'eau a trop fait j'arrivais sur un
plateau il jouait matos qui était une
toune de ici d'ici là qui font d'eux et
joie cet automne la torah que
j'arrêterai là sur une émission de télé
le tien fait que les musiciens ils me
connaissent et qui quand je me levais
sud barjots retomber là oui pendant l
accès j'avais j'étais toujours de
connivence avec le band tout le temps
tout est quatre gars disent aujourd'hui
les vidéos de tesquet tous deux
apparitions tv est ce qu ont parlé avec
jean thomas jobin de ses pizzas ses
premiers sketches she is comme s'ils
reconnaissaient pour et oui quand hit
west
est ce que tu te vois toi ou tu vois
quelqu'un d'autre ouais même quand j'ai
joué dans la série de jules verne
cvitanich je m'efforçais d'avoir un
personnage puis quand on a regardé les
palais des provinces émission qui
grimacent latine j'avais peur je savais
pas comment vraiment écrire un sketch à
la pause a été long je décroche
comment écrire un sketch plus comment y
arriver puis du début à la fin
ping à la fin c'était plus facile à
écrire parce que j'avais même mécanique
mais je m'en rappelle même pas ce que je
voulais oui oui oui mais je ne vois pas
différemment de ce que je suis dans la
vie tu juges tout le temps demain - un
jeu toujours en tête parce que mouche
quelqu'un de très ludique l'été j'aime
pauvres quand c'est trop sérieux je me
sens mon nico ses sofas grand jo où ça
sera quoi la pirogue à faire à ce moment
alors où ça serait quoi le contrat ce
que je pourrais dire par rapport à telle
affaire
alors j'aime ce jeu ne souffre mais je
me souviens simplement dans un chariot
mais c'est pas c'est pas pour ma famille
j'aime souffrir les gens mais ça c'est
ici ni la ccid en cédant ces tendances
et tant qu'à moi c'est juste 10
c'est juste vouloir donner puissant
légaux qui vient dit que c'est la
meilleure et a produit ce suisse est
juste de mettre un peu de poids pendant
serait prétentieux mais un peu de
plaisir
bon le palace pour une accumulation de
plaisir mais de jusqu'à relaxer les gens
les faire décrocher quotidien puis c'est
juste comme qu'espère d'hypnose tu vois
des mieux se produit enfin que faire je
traiterai j'aime faire rire les gens
mais de là on en revient vite et aussi
tout ce qu'un arrière jeudi en mettant
la tournée ce qu'on voit ce que public
voici le moment où c'est sur scène que
le monde rit mais a tourné jeudi le
dépôt chez vous tout en déplacement dit
quelque chose de
le moment aux côtés sur scène tu fais
vraiment ta job il ya tout un arrière
scène convention l'attraction du taf
mais là dedans parce que je connais je
regarde un mode de vie qui est pas le
but de la bonbonne de vie mais moi j'ai
été déracinés jamais j'aurais été
capable de vie en france j'avais jamais
j'aurai des câbles de vie en allemagne
en espagne en angleterre alors que
jamais le québec
j'aime être chez moi jamais surpris
quand je partais samedi j'ai perdu
beaucoup de jeunes j'ai perdu beaucoup
d'amis ma famille je la voyais plus
partie des blondes par tout le monde en
faisant quelque chose qui est ce que si
tu avais fait c'était à nîmes et en
vingt ans plus tard
est ce que maintenant tu ferais des
crèches et vous tu seras ma femme était
très discrète je te mettrai sur youtube
mettons plutôt que de déplacer de voir
sur scène justement à éviter
je sais pas je sais pas
si maintenant on avait une c'est sûr que
si on avait eu des iphones ya 20 ans il
ya vingt cinq ans peut-être que je
serais encore en tournée parce que je
reverrai ma blonde tu te rends avec les
autres la liste
j'avais cellulaire ça existait même pas
c'est un radio téléphone que j'avais dit
que les intérêts fixés complique il est
en contact si c'était faisable il
fallait je donne des rendez vous un marc
blondel époque que j'avais à l'époque
hockey mardi 14 heures ça va sonner
enfin que ça se ferait supporter un an
je comprends je comprends qu'ils
s'écartent commencé télé eu une espèce
de deux brickdown puis de chute le
dessus qui a été assez médiatisé je
pense le puits après après ça quand tu
sors de thérapie c'est comment sais tu
te retrouves je reprends contrôle de de
la direction du but à vie prennent c'est
long c'est vraiment c'est vraiment non
surtout quand est bipolaire t1 stable
avec un peu tombé pour monter tu peux
tomber tu peux remonter fakaté bip
hollande ce même pack elite dans le sens
que la chine à 600 mètres quand même un
soulagement oui oui pour moi salim et à
verdun que même moi sa mort sous l'égide
de compris quelque chose
ah ben oui mais là bas j'ai compris tout
mon comportement quand on m'expliquer
c'était quoi la main à dix huit ans
barman à partir de loches avec quoi
faire je songe à prendre les moyens pour
ça se guérit paume malheureusement j'ai
encore des crises
aujourd'hui c'est surtout encore plus
pendant la pandémie parce que c'est la
solitude correct mais d'isolement
s'étoffant tabakman
si tu avais pas l'air ne s'est pas le
fond fait que le truc j'ai trouvé ça
vraiment de beaucoup m'occuper le
cerveau logique ij monde je réalise un
paquet de projets en même temps
mais j'essaye d'en revenir à ta question
ben comme comment est-ce qu'une fois que
tu lui apprends que tout le diagnostic
tu reprends ta vieux longue démarche ans
et une très longue démarche
faux faux polar chez moi ça fait 22 ans
que je sais que je suis bipolaire moins
ça fait 21 ans que j'ai encore ce que la
maladie bipolaire as modifie donc t'as
jamais le même comportement sans jamais
les mêmes réactions tout jamais les
mêmes émotions que jamais je sais jamais
été et qui à quel moment
des fois je peux être dans un rail
bipolaire je m'en rends pas compte
puisque des affaires que le lendemain je
m'affaire rapprocher faire quoi j'ai dit
oui j'ai 17 ans et je filais peau trois
jours plus tard je tenais vraiment à
israël
puis quand tu dis des affaires quand
t'es dingue c'est là c'est la même
affaire mais c'est pas quelque chose qui
se maîtrise de la médication qui voici
de niveler le mieux qu'apple mais c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment ton mental à
tours puis de l'accepter aussi des
bipolaires c'est ce qui est des bambins
important mais c'est à eux de toto
analyser tout le temps parce que moi
c'est ma sortie 17 nazaire qui j'ai
parlé d'être rude entre ses grilles
naxitis justice quelque chose d'utile de
quoi que je suis dans un bon moyen c'est
patent de l'anxiété que d'essayer
d'analyser pour voir parce que je suis
toujours à payer car j'ai une crise du
polar ou pas c'est tellement pernicieux
nous avions tellement la peine tu t'en
aperçois proprement dit ne pas tabler la
pète up fois que ça m'arrivait quand on
fait de la tournée puis on était au
début de la tournée gens qui envoyait
même où des foules à six par semaine
alors oui quatre mois en ligne tatatata
hockey le monde à sa rentrée ça mais
lyon le camp jardin est rejetée sans
geindre fallait geler phase les quatre
mondes et
parce que t'es pas juste dans le mental
mans physiquement de plus de force
et quand tu voyais quand est d'avoir un
job tu voyais les choix rvc le je pense
qu'on avait dit des photos de mes potes
c'était vraiment le titre citoyen se
contentant d'un spectacle le mauvais
traque ses mails et de tso aussi parce
qu'au début de tracklist est vraiment
fan mais là c'est devenu quintrec
négatif donc ce qu'on dit bon qu'à
l'extérieur depuis avec à l'extérieur et
donc ça me paralyse m
le trac non je leur parle des calmants
pour pas des du rivotril
mais c'est un médicament c'est dans la
famille des benzodiazépines aps c 13
addictif du alors j'ai j'ai pris soin
parents d animer la dose alors que lens
avait plus de sens j'étais comme une
balle qu'en faisait chaud parce que
j'étais beaucoup trop nerveux inquiet
peut-être trop de monde
des fois je faisais des places il y
avait 2000 personnes 2005 3000 et ya
main et je te rappelle j'étais partie du
stage parce que je voulais aller dans le
fond pour chopper quoi mais le public
telle au chalet dans le fond puis quand
je parlais y avait un délai je me disais
qu'il hall s'est cru à tarnac en main
comme ça là c'était hallucinant le train
intervenant avant sa mort comme dany le
ton un peu de haut s'était rendu dans ma
carrière l'autre quand c'est rendu que
tu es plus loin que le son
chose qu'il ya quand même une surenchère
jeudi ont fait des grosses machines ça
maintient la pression
puis la consommation c'est sûr que ça
aide pas à régulariser la bipolarité
ben en fait là non c'est de l'auto
médication amateurs mais moi j'ai jamais
consommé avant par le rapport ces
médicaments a pas à part les médicaments
oui les drogues légales mais ça c'était
dessus aussi c'était légal mais ce que
c'était prescrits ou stéréo et c'est
prescrit kaki que ça venait dé mai mais
non je n'ai jamais pris de drogue j'ai
jamais tout le monde pense que c'est
chaud de partout c'était pas ça prend
tout ce que j'avais tellement peau
j'avais tellement de la difficulté à
gérer mon stress que je perdais la
mémoire puis quand je rentrais sur cette
méthode de la télé je partage je perdais
le contrôle qu'il en est un
un contrôle sur le chaos le ttt sur
l'adrénaline feu a complètement gtl
explosif je voulais pas montrer que tu
es nerveux mais que j'étais fou tout est
correct si tu t'endors de relance de ces
moments là aussi comme des blacks are de
décéder dans la 4 apple a pour seul en
vue mais trois pelles pour rappel qui
était à radio canada mais tu te
rappelles peau que 110 pendant
l'entrevue n'a rien de quoi si j patins
à roulettes et nerveux je forçais pas
consommer la cdc qui ont marqué le monde
à ce point et le sexy go ou encore
aujourd'hui 2 6 bat les personnes qui
faisaient sa fenêtre moi j'ai toujours
essayé d'aller où ce que personne
n'avait été que vous faites les choses
les choses différemment à rouyn
tlj sauf aller différemment tout le
monde bref après sa période le lot ne
tombe en période d'heure de consommation
des plus pissos
oui j'étais âge était mon père oui
drague mais ça a duré trois ans
parce que moi on m'avait dit si trois
grâces populaire soit heureux 3 la
maison la femme de philippe ça ne change
que tous voudrons toi tu ottawa ce qui
est arrivé c'est juste un an au point où
telle que les plus populaires du moment
puis pâte afin tout petit ami de famille
c'est ce succès fait était seul en haut
de la montagne saisir mais je sais quoi
je partage avec quichotte il partait
avec mon jean je sais quoi je peux pas
aller plus haut c'est après c'est sûr la
stratosphère là le clash tramontane marc
pittie si tu places sont offertes 500
ambiance houssin son os x 2,5 mais de
bien c'est la même peine et le jeter
dans le salon chez moi puis je regardais
le ce qui m'arrivait tout ce que j'avais
perdu pour paraître il faut genre
descendre la montagne points parce que
les gens vont dire plus je veux savoir
ce que je dis pas ce que je vaux pro ben
je vois pas bien souvent parce que quand
tu es bipolaire tu des hallucinations
aussi auditive ou visuelle et ça
m'arrivait souvent backstage
des fois quand j'attendais pour monter
sur scène puisqu'elle y avait juste les
murmures dans la salle tout serai
meilleur que je me mettais à entendre
des voix ou voir des gens passaient dans
les coulisses où le jamais pas ce depuis
sa chatte est toujours une présence
comme fantomatique derrière mon frère
toujours me tourner vers quelqu'un fait
les débuts de chaux pour moi ça
m'angoisse elle joua pas être seul puis
la fin de chou rouge courait dans ma
loge pourquoi avoir à passer dans les
rideaux noirs puis est tout sauf que
j'étais rendu vraiment paranoïaque là
c'est la maladie mentale était vraiment
souvent été très très très aigu le temps
où tu entends des trucs puis le titre
seulement là c'est pas possible tu es
donc c'est ça c'est sûr ça aide la
pharmacologie loi empêchait d'en attend
dé voir puis d'aborder et les
hallucinations
mais ça ne c'est un élément de stress
très s'amorce à m'entraîner longtemps
fait que oui fait impression surtout tu
ressens mettons le youtube érable
pendant bout a pas trop savoir où aller
tu rentres interview de quelqu'un qui te
faire entrer en thérapie où ses parts à
propre annonce que je me rappelle ces
montants marquent désourdy qui habitait
chez moi parce qu'il sait paraître sa
femme
je t'ai entendu l'accueil grenouille le
topping investis qui se perd mais chez
nous et c'est une grosse maison
c'est lui en fait lui état dit dans
cette clinique de désintoxication m'a
suggéré année j'aurai tous connaissaient
comme un problème ou pour vous tous les
parents n'ont pas est bon à consommer
consommer finalement il ya un matin je
suis sauf haut dans l'arrière de rien
puis je vois probable tant qu'elles sont
sûres faut que j'adore mais plus mon
gérant de l'époque et est venu boire
pillay a dit il faut trois à quoi puis
au début j'étais je pensais qu'ils
n'aient vraiment un mauvais geste à moi
comme ça mon com touché acquittement
l'atypique insistait le type pour qu'on
parte même aujourd'hui la clinique
pour voir après puis tatatata temps et
finalement j'ai été à la clinique
je suis allé dire aux gens d'abobo fois
rentrés dans une semaine juste le temps
de régler mes enfants et puis non non
non rendre suite on va t'emmener ton
linge je ne comprenais pas le joueur
venait dans une semaine survient
drapeaux ainsi ils viennent jamais ne
reviennent jamais non mais moi je vois
revenez et a participé partir pendant
une semaine j'ai comme fait mes adieux
est passé et puis je rappeler une
semaine après un clinic très surpris de
me voir et quand vous êtes en tout que
cette personne n'allait pas que j'avais
été très touché de son intention de le
semaine plus tard que j'étais dans la
clinique qui y amener quelqu'un pour me
proposer des projets mais rejetant
clinique de désintox ben ouais puis tu
m'amènes du monde des projets ch'ti j'ai
compris que ils voulaient me désintox
tout commence à tourner sur cinq fait
bon ok ce chèque fait que ça a été ça a
été éprouvant
ça a été un deux semaines pas mal faut
qu'il tire ne se désintéresse pas de
tout ce stock leur qui veut facilement
ça a été bien difficile mentalement
physiquement je dormais plus je dirige
des convulsions pas ta femme et il ya
même un journaliste des journalistes
sont nés à la clinique pour savoir
qu'est ce qui se passe avec moi non et
puis y en a un qui a essayé de prendre
des photos quand j'étais dans la cave où
on était traité de la gagne 1,26 à l'on
écoute atv que j'ai levé les yeux puis
vainqueur avec son appareil photo est
parti lui le qui vont payer la gagner
pour
mais si c'est pour dire plutôt chiche
qui texte c'est samedi gatx qui m'ont
dit ça ça fait 21 ans maintenant 22 ans
mais enfin 22 ans le 23 puis combien de
temps ça te prie après ça tu disais
tantôt une période que tu te faisais
rien de rien fait après je me cherche un
peu trembler je voulais faire la
réalisation il n'y avait pas de projet
qui fait que le rail est vite fait
mchugh jeu comme fait un paquet
d'affaires loterie sauve la réalisation
pisser pendant la pandémie que j'ai
décidé de notre remettre sur pieds quand
ma tv parce que j'avais eu l'idée à
l'époque une vingtaine d'années non mais
ça coûtait trop cher alors que les
cameron la location et c'était parti de
cette partie devant une vingtaine
d'années c'était c'était quoi derrière
l'idée de vouloir faire comme un tv
c'était juste d'acier de partir un pass
internet quand j'ai vu que l'internet
existait des fautes assez bien cotée
séparément des émissions pourraient
tourner des affaires pas cher non au
concept de netflix bien avant le temps
mais en fait de tournée des mini série
pour l'internet losc solide et puis
surtout avec les propres moyens avec un
an
ça m'a pris du temps avant de réfléchir
à un mode d'affaires
un mode de paiement qui téléphonent
autre que la subvention parce que cook
est différents sites et la subvention
peut-être pas ce à quoi il faut
s'attendre les fois qu'il faut que les
affaires roulent et d'impliquer les gens
qui qui qui pondent les projets qu'ils
veulent les faire monter l'été c'était
un fait récent comme comme projet nous
aurons je prends vraiment proche de nous
c'est moins sylvain desjardins qui s'est
greffée au projet il ya paul n'y a pas
si longtemps et on veut créer un
écosystème de création québécoise sur la
plateforme des gens qui vont s'entraider
comédien et réalisateur parce que les
caisses le monde qui travaille pour le
yang ne sais pas si vous avez vu moi
j'ai eu à l'infolettre de l'idée aux
puissants me donner froid dans le dos
41% des artistes veulent se trouver un
job autres que l'iphone est lente parce
qu'on n'a plus foulé vous il faut
s'avouer ans nous hockey au québec on
n'a pas les moyens nos idées et c'est
pour ça que tout les subventionner on
est un point on est un petit à petit
peuple était pas un pub de petits mais
un petit peuple
on est huit millions pas tout
francophone et puis on essaye de se
débrouiller du mugron peu mais on n'a
pas les moyens
enfin la télé on n'a pas les moyens
fendant radio n'a pas les moyens de
faire du théâtre et pour mieux défendre
la danse
on n'a pas les moyens j'ai tout dit
subventionné n'y a aucun il ya aucun
marché sauf
il ya juste l'humour a tourné d'un
spectacle qui fera une mise en autant de
l'ehess la télé on veut faire de la télé
les autres pays mais sa cote chez moi
qu'est ce qu'on fait n'est subventionné
ça vaut 2000 par savo dalta cas tout de
suite aux émissions pour sa part sa
terrible tout ça a presque fini avec
méthode je te moques que toutes les
émissions qu'on garde subventionnés la
culture sautant ses ventes nettes vois
surtout comme une bonne chose comme
mauvaise chose non il faut il faut
il faut être au courant il faut le
savoir qu'on est tout subventionné puis
quand on vit sur le vix sur quelque
chose qui est est ce que même machine à
respirer la teen movie sur une machine
on est plug in by ce la machine s'était
en effet fait qu'il faut trouver pour ça
que quand j'ai participé à ma tv du faux
faire un modèle d'affaires qui est
typiquement québécois qui va devenir
typiquement québécois niveau nous
suffire à nous autres pour faire nos
affaires
puis c'est parfait parce que les gens
vont utiliser ça pour se pratiquer
quasiment retient pour faire des séries
pour voir comment ça se réalise mon idée
est bonne je peux te faire une version 5
minutes 30 minutes pour je vois que ça
donne c'est une piste unique ifu il n'y
a plus il ya de la liberté de création
incroyable
ce qui fait que moi je pour l'avoir
véhicule a mené un projet chez un
producteur qui lui encore pour le
diffuseur tout le monde mode letton à
faire pour que ça fait avec les
diffuseurs je sois yatera ou whereas you
can ou un télé québec au bla bla bla
hélas après ça quand tu arrives sur le
diffuseur hôte ils veulent le modeler
pour la clientèle pour leurs annonceurs
après ça a un coût que c'est un coup
c'est écrit tout cela les avocats
rentrer là dedans - berceau ça vaut
chienlit la ligue des bradeurs la job de
bras le pays assure en même temps ils
font comme nous autres on peut pas on
peut pas sur istres scénario lent parce
que vous parlez de dentier et puis la
ligue des dentistes infinie puck en lice
mais ça finit plus et un filtre part à
l'entraînement dans ton ton coefficient
adore qui est à 100% au début au bout de
la ligne il 13 15 - pour ça c'est
ridicule ça qu'on saura jamais ce l'idée
était bonne non à un juste été adapté et
plus de 10 ans qui se plaignent pu qui
eût pu rien
est-ce que j'ai deux questions la
première c
dans l'idée si on part de l'idée que on
n'est pas assez nombreux pour s'auto
suffire qui se financer en fait c'est
pas ça c'est qu'il faut trouver une
façon de s'autosuffire sonné juste 8
millions c'est pas ce problème fait qu
est-ce qui est ce que dans ce calcul
oeuvre dans ce plan d'affaires l'heure
on a un marché qui est assez grand pour
être capable de éventuellement mais
j'aime une ére ce genre de projet hope
ce qu'on veut c'est la francophonie
mondiale
- qu'est ce qui est quand même un nom ce
qui est quand même énorme doute la
nordev et l'europe
la thaïlande le vietnam nature
toutes les équipes qui parle dont la
seconde langue est le français où la
première dame de france est déjà réussie
il avec laurent nous qui nous a mis sur
comment tv enfin quand on a on va avoir
du matériel journée des autres pays
aussi ce qui fait que on va avoir un
pays virtuel avec eux au lieu d'être le
2 millions ce qu'il est vraiment plus
ses soeurs entamée puis ton en vaut être
reconnu dans d'autres pays aussi parce
que quand tu fais de la télé au québec
mais leur fauteuil au mythe fauteuil
vantaa petite émission télé puis souvent
les gens me posent ils y achètent ils
achètent des concepts qui reviennent si
on le fait les autres avec caméra café
ya plusieurs années où on a carrément
pris un concept français parce que je
serai certain que si on avait proposé un
concept comme caméra café jeux sur
papier ça se serait jamais fait
ouais mais le fait de l'avoir vu attivi
puis à bassam à abbas que tu diminues là
tu diminues le facteur risque le risque
et tu parlais tantôt que plus de risques
ce prince est un concept crise qui se
posera marché ayant déjà été prouvée
comme la voix mettons le
rien à voir c'est sûr que tu as peu
poche il ça passe après heureux dans
tout que je pense que certaines séries
qui ont malheureusement c'est plate pour
les autres pas marché en fait un des
officiers quoi le patois n'y est avant
tout est bon à prendre mais ce que je
voulais dire c'est qu'il ya bien des pas
d'aidé du produit qui viennent de
l'europe où entre de la francophonie qui
a un coût traduit ben c'est pas ça donne
pas les résultats qu'on veut mais ce que
je trouve un dab surpris c'est qu'on
adapte un show qui vient d'un autre pays
et kankan des prix pour ses créations ou
un thé chaud show télé de l'année où on
est on à moi je pense que quand tu
prends un proche d'un autre pays tu l'as
d'aptitude fait chez vous ça devrait te
dis que c'est une adaptation que c'est
pas un produit à 100 % québécoise s'est
pas uni des québécois moi je pense qu'il
faut mettre l'emphase sur ces fêtes au
québec crée par des québécois
et puis voilà puis à partir de l'eau
peut-être que nous aurons plus
l'exporter mais gagner des breaks
quelque chose déjà été fait
tous ordinaire je sens vraiment bien moi
je me senti beaucoup important là qu'on
faisait
caméra café parce que c'était ma boîte
de production qui manque qu'il faisait
est-ce que tu écrivais aussi break
américains n'ont pensé qu'à un sketch je
te prends le bus rockets annoncé quant à
françois avant qu'il se trouvait seul
face au gardien
redevenir humble et non jeu qui va pas
là dessus mais j'avais toujours
l'impression que oui temps on fait de la
daily mail c'est pas nous au petit on
prend vraiment quelque chose qui venait
d'ailleurs puis qu'on adapte et puis
qu'on a fait on n'a pas eu le plaisir de
succès ces dix jeux dans 100 pays
je pense que c'est con ce concept là de
caméra café
c'est partout le nom et avoir eu des
loges arrêter ben quoi comme dit avec un
gars une fille liban compte mais
justement un gars une fille c'est
vraiment un bon exemple de création
originale qui s'exporte super bien et
aussi l'aube aux jets
oui c'est que kissinger quel genre de
séries qui se porteraient super vient de
battre forme comme absolument tv films
ceci suggère de direction tu veux que ça
prenne pas ce que l'on peut voir déjà
d'aider certains
certaines bandes annonces et un look
assez simple comme celui ouais ben moi
en fait j'ai tourné avec mon téléphone
ouais j'ai mis une application dessus
qui coûta après 15 pias j'ai acheté des
petits microbes loue depuis j'ai fait
mes tournages avec ça s'il a en fait la
démocratisation de la technologie
gardez votre duke c'est la
démocratisation de la technologie qui
fait que tout est possible maintenant
sur la plate forme et est ce que l'idée
c'est d'éventuellement avoir des
productions à plus grand déploiement
plus grand budget puis à plus grandes
équipes ou cds le plus minimaliste en
termes de moi je dirais on va voir
comment ça va évoluer mais c'est sûr que
les séries d'une damian 13 épisodes
d'une dernière d'après mon nom c'est
repos possible mais on sait jamais parce
qu'on va peut-être se mettra fin de la
production aussi des séances ion on est
vendue dans plusieurs pays alors
voici mais moi ce que je favoris si
cette forme là cinq fois cinq minutes ça
s'écoute bien en plus on va diffuser
bientôt en quatre corps on voit sur les
téléphones juan l'application téléphone
l'application de la télé tu vas pouvoir
utiliser ta télévision quatre corps pour
les vrais parce que vous l'avez pas
entendu si donc je pense avoir un moyen
aussi de rallier les deux générations
les parents qui veulent écouter attivi 4
coop les gens veulent des formats courts
à écouter leurs vedettes préférées où
volent les humoristes préférées parce
qu'on vise pas nécessairement avoir que
des humoristes non on vise en avoir des
gens qui sont bon festin pu le prendre
mais ton genre des sketches toujours des
capsules qui sont faits par les maurice
méthon petit sommet sur youtube et dire
ok ou lutte de masse une plate-forme ou
de visionner tous ceux des sélects à
manseau en fait ce qu'on demande en ce
moment c'est ça peut être cinq sketches
où ça peut être tout la même série aussi
ça c'est le kit de départ le fait que
les gens nous ce qu'on leur conseille
ceux de tout tournant 4 comme et
exportant 12,80 que nous ordonner sur la
plate forme et on monétise leur travail
que votre série 5 minutes on la met 5 99
et elle est en location on la vend pour
elle est en location pour empêcher que
les gens plus copie des fichiers pour
protéger les robes ce qui est le fun
c'est que comme c'est une diffusion ben
ça peut compter six seront copiés wever
on a la preuve c'est que les diffuser
pis ça ton coefficient d'or comme je
t'embrouille pas mal à 100% nous était
content comme c'est écrit piquets serrés
elle dit on est content pour tout bon
le diffusée l'été alors qu'en tout cas
tout cela est prête c'est soit que les
gens louent par par émission ou forfait
par mois ou par année puis l'on sent
bien quand un forfait ravi aussi bientôt
qui est plus un forfait data de la plate
forme là dans les prochains mois j'ai
beaucoup de développement d'un boom
beaucoup beaucoup de développement il ya
beaucoup de monde qui m'a pêche bien
content qu'ils veulent prendre contact
avec moi pour me proposer des enfants
puis franchement zinc à 90% du temps
c'est vraiment bon c'est ça la
différence à un peu avec la terrisse
éclaté l'ivoire fusil ton projet pas
parce qu il pas bon c'est parce que ça
gîte pop et puis on travaille avec eux
avec la télé dis moi ce que tu veux pas
qu'à l'écrire moi monsieur monsieur
athènes c'est quoi tu veux comme projet
monsieur tv ne se réveillant monsieur
radio canada madd pas son combat qu ils
disent non c'est fini c'est fini
le säntis six adultes requis un thalys
com c'est qui le public cible si on va
écrire telle sound mais c'est dans un
sens si netflix un peu aussi dans leurs
productions originales et comme ils sont
prêts la farce ou moins qu'ils nous
avaient rester sauf qu ils savent qu'ils
ont telle cible de toutes les données
tout le monde ils savent qu'ils et elles
telle types de spectateurs qui tripent
sur tel acteur qui trippent sauter le
sujet à travers une série sur mesure
pour lui ces méta les documents qu'ils
vont faire un documentaire sur sur les
gens qui jouaient à l'époque aux
machines vidéo les familles à faire des
contes aux enfants même s'habille pas
intéressant où ils font un reportage sur
les lego où ils font un reportage ses
portefeuilles ou mais tout est bien fait
c'est bien raconter ce qu'elle mène la
qualité bbc nathan regarde j'ai
l'impression
j'ai l'impression que des grosses
plateformes comme ça ils fonctionnent
vraiment avec ses leurs coups de circuit
qui finance le reste des séries le mans
sur netflix qui s'appelle last thing you
fixé comme des des athlètes
universitaires qui n'ont pas réussi à
rentrer dans des gros collège fait
qu'ils rentrent dans des collèges
publics t voyez que l'oeil essaye de à
travers deux en collèges publics gagner
une place bien jusqu'à leur chipe fait
qu'un des bourses pour aller d'un gros
quart htpc huit épisodes d'une heure qui
suivent une équipe mais c'est réaliser
le c'est fou la qualité de cette
chaufferie londres est que c'est
scénarisé bien ça a dû coûter le des
millions de dollars sur des millions et
millions puis ils doivent pas être
rentable avec ce parce qu'il n'y a pas
assez de monde qui vont l'écouter
sûrement cette série loti parce qu'ils
coûtent trop cher pour ce que finalement
un documentaire qui suit une équipe de
basketball étudiante les tigres mais
c'est sûrement leur bureau gros
blockbusters qui amène vrai on sait
combien par mois explique sylvain place
au doute respiration c'était monte à 15
mètres 12e
je vais avec combien de millions de ses
autres brownies partout dans le monde
c'est cela la différente la difficulté
de faire de quoi en français c'est un
méchant défi m aurait absolument
absolument
c'est sûr que non il faut il faut faire
dacquois parce que là il ya quand même
là c'est catastrophique ce qu'on vit en
ce moment la pandémie le virus tout ça
c'est une catastrophe
on sera peut-être pas de bon sens on
devait aller tous là les au départ enfin
le team est un masque lave les mains
stif à bouillé débats devant notre télé
ni tremper les pieds dans l'eau chaude
exactement fa cup
mettons que alors il faut il faut faire
de quoi il faut faire travailler ses
jambes
il faut leur trouver de la job les
comédiens les réalisateurs les 100 m les
accessoires explique maquillage name est
là il faut que les gens travaillent
c'est ce qui est plus valorisant
c'est bon l'internet vient tout
brouiller les cartes si on a vu à la
télévision fonctionne 30 façon que si
les cotes d'écouté tel le team et on je
regarde mes tongs star academy team dont
la nouvelle version
j'ai l'impression plus je connais pas
les chiffres mais j'ai l'impression
qu'ils essayent de face qui faisait dans
le temps avec une fraction du budget ou
du pipi dans le temps je dis à tout le
monde et que ta télé le et en une
génération complète qui écoutent plus à
télévision pan tout ce qui regarde les
enfants se sur youtube pca qui commet
qu'ont réussi à piquer les artisans de
ce médium le gagnent leur vie ont
consulté la lave un système avec les
publicités je voudrais pour le meilleur
et pour le pire meetic qui fonctionnait
pour moi je pense que c'est après ces
puits si tout le monde s'en va ça sur
internet allons-y le tien c'est juste
que la france je ne trouvais que en
début de pandémie mais mais mais sommes
allés chacun de là bas
romanello mon mal est là mon mari le
youtube c'est tout le monde n'était pas
pimms s est plaint tout ce total le kit
atteindre 200 ali pourquoi qu'on fait
pas toutes à la même place pour qu'un
agent de youtube netflix denis où tout
le monde voit converger bombay lost raté
artistes préférés il son lot de jeux
salle elop bien appeler un dos c'était
projet de jeu ça les fouiller dans
youtube ou fouiller d'un patron ou
fouiller dans vimeo
un autre enfin facebook instagram
tu vas voir l'autre verra pas ce qui se
passe le lotir par disque et a commenté
rhys tu vois que tu vas voir ce qui se
passe une liste de gens parce qu'on va
juste faire les émissions de télé on va
faire des dépôts de l'italie mais des
mini séries on va faire aussi du
streaming
on va faire on va diffuser du film on va
diffuser des shows live c'est tout ça
s'en vient le tiens on va on va mettre
plusieurs arca note de cordes à notre
arc pour justement attirer tous ces gens
là la vente de dvd et patati patata
admettons quitte à céder
je prends un exemple simple des
humoristes de la relève qui décide de
mettre de vous approcher pour mettre
leur spectacle captation live le pilote
mettons une personne comme 100 breton
qui va amener beaucoup beaucoup
d'abonnés à la plateforme probablement
avec son spectacle je dirais que j'ai
aucune des six membres dont il veut
faire un film
pita un autre humoriste un petit peu
moins connus qui a aussi son show sa
plateforme le même temps je m'abonne
pour par mois c'est sur la plateforme
est ce que après ça les revenus sont
divisés selon le no more atteint au
prorata du nombre des coups de feu at on
tant d'un côté que c'est bénéfique pour
tout le monde au sens unique amène
beaucoup de monde va recevoir de
l'argent mais qu'il y avait eu moins de
monde un peuvent aussi bénéficier
oui d écoute et d abonnement quelqu'un
de fiction c'est super intéressant je
t'entends des durées c'est 1 75 c'est ce
que j'allais dire si c'est canteloup à
la pièce moutons à l'émission bâton une
bien ce qu'est alberto 30% qui sont en
vo un coma terry comme plateforme
marketing soutien technique
soixante dix pour cent des profits vont
à la personne qui produit son agent son
usine ont absolument
mais en même temps c'est quand même ma
non mais c'est sain et sauf
facal est passé quelque chose dans ton
lit je pense que tu mentionnait que toi
tu avais tu étais avec juste pour rire
le jeune ben non moi je veux c'est avec
françois ozon qui tu disais dans ton
livre que le split des 55 ans mais ceci
dit c'est démesuré et dans un cadre de
spectacles live sur scène coproduction
lieu pato mais sur tout
là ça marche et de bulles parce que je
te faisais m en est jeté tellement tanné
donner toute la moitié de ce que faisait
un madani je me rappelle j'avais comme
une semaine de vacances et et l'homme
mon gérant l'époque m'appelle puidoux à
beloeil yotel compagnie de pétrole qui
aimerait savoir un peu je me reposais
latine pipe band c'est quand même trois
cent cinquante mille jean api trophy le
dit c'est beaucoup d'argent
là dans ma tête me suis dit c'est pour
350 milles ces 350 milles / 2 / 2 parce
que ma cote à savon au géant puis
l'autre ça sans avoir aux impôts 3
ça fait soixante quinze mille je pense
par deux puis combine j'ai perdu ma ton
180 ces 90 minutes pour 350 n'est pas
faire accroire que ces 350 90
c'est quoi le thème maladie mentale
parce que c'est tellement
décourageant travail et de même quatre
autres 50% qui penche sur tout un
essayage de costumes de payer 150 pièces
qui vivent près parce que tu faisais peu
époque bob et missions téléfilm la série
britannique que j'ai tourné jules verne
ils ne paient comme 400-450 bien ce
pouvoir pour l'année à la moitié par
terre puis l'autre monde et qui partait
maintenant c'est décourageant quand un
agent il va pas en 10 et 15%
bon mais pour cinq ans j'aimerais en lui
c'est à partir de 5 ans
mais je totalement à car à l'époque s'il
ya beaucoup de ma faute la partie gérée
personnes le protéger mais parce que
comme il est temps j'ai un pote mais
devant celui qui se profile
ça y est où la personne qui me protège
la de bain parce que je pensais qu'en
tant que gérant tu laisserais un autre
producteur prendre 50% des enfants de sa
remplaçante n'est ce pas mais c'était
une conversation tour pierre mais j'ai
abandonné beaucoup aussi à cause de
l'abus je pense qu avec marilou qu'on
parle de tickets elles se parent jeune
alain gros succès par la grosse équipe
ittihad disaient les gens qui sont
supposés protéger un souci les gens qui
me poussera faire plus parce qu'ils ont
une part du gâteau qu'est vraiment un
conflit d'intérêt bon il faut qu'il paye
la tête après leur faux
moi j'ai besoin d'un cabanon petit
l'impression aujourd'hui mettant avec ce
qui est fait et enfin enfin mais ce que
tout le temps voulu faire finalement
quitté plus job an irien que je suis
c'est quand tu dis le malheur des gens
faibles par exemple moi je suis un
poisson dans l'eau je suis à la maison
schmidt tournage je mets ça dans mon
imac
ah ouais choix du montage découvre du
logiciel de fans aux bottes ça me tient
le cerveau vraiment benno q p ça peut
pas être mieux pour pour moi les pieds
pour les allemands puis la pandémie tout
seul dans le meilleur scénario m'a
sortir mais est ce que est ce que malgré
tout ça reste du cil j'imagine comme
tout le monde je manquais pour tout le
monde whip it et qu'en même temps un
projet oui la personne que dans quatre
mois foutu livre le projet ben cheikh
tentant pour quatre mois en énergie ton
temps mais on ne sait pas c'est quoi
qu'est ce que je fais dans la parade du
belge de l'énergie là dessus puis après
ce bain de l'énergie est reçue puis je
me les gens s'éparpillent ainsi ça
cherche sa chair ça crée des angoisses
des états de panique un incroyable c'est
sûr c'est qu'on a tous dit on a toutes
envie que ça finisse au plus vite
puis que mon mais la manif vidéos sont
vides et puis tard chargé d'installer
pas facile mais comment tu fais après le
même temps la tige pc eee pc et re a
cédé rejoindre en plus sain possible
c'est l'enfant de l'enfant puis comment
s'entraider puis commenté lisons nous
rend ce qu'on nous le dise on roule
magath mannequin mais c'est compliqué on
sait plus qui écoutait en région le
masque des gants
non je souffre je suis loin après neuf
ans non ça avant avant nom ne fait pas
qu arrive à 6 non non moi je pars à 7
tabarnak à moi pour dyslexique c'est pas
facile
ouais
c'est que ce 10e jeu m'a plu ce qui est
sûr c'est que ce lexique et et des
insectes c'est l'enfance concentré haas
et du déconcentré trempé dans le
décompte en avril
c'est moi je te dis 'ah alors
travail-études un conflit autour tout
sera ok la joie les locaux mais je suis
dyslexique pas capables d'apprendre des
textes pour capable de ce programme est
de lire sauf des scénarios qui est un
miracle de mai lire un livre je lis deux
lignes puis je disais que je revienne là
paravent entend par l'enjeu pas capable
d'aller manger un trouble vraiment de
déficit d'attention puis que la dyslexie
ça est repos du tour j'apprends avec des
couleurs quand je fais des mémés montage
je dois mettre la première ligne verte
après ce genre mais le rouge plus je me
rappelle qu'elle est orange parce qu'ils
portaient des genres on ice est
complètement fou tu te débrouilles là
dedans mais sa réponse à une question
simple observation puis est ce que
j'imagine que ceux ci s'étaient pas
garde à prendre des textes
j'imagine que c'est une des raisons
pourquoi je fais pas de texte ou jamais
fait de textes le dessus ah ben je n'ai
jamais vu de blancs de mémoire famille
mes sketches jamais après je sais - pays
aujourd'hui
mais quand je faisais mathon
le bye bye bye bye puis que je faisais
vrai que la vie c'était une hantise
genre en un mois d'avant ce que j'étais
comme soja ça rentrait pas dans ma tête
j'ai répété j'ai répété je me trompe pas
tout le temps gérer péchenard sous le
train a pas être capable d'apprendre
mais mes textes mais ça c'est un peu le
trac aussi qu'ils faisaient que moi mais
là il t'arrive à un miracle dans ma vie
la bonne nouvelle c'est que moins le
trac ça m'a toujours empêchés de faire
de la scène
sauf que je suis allé voir une note et
puis et c'est ce qui a fait c'est que
y'a comme fait comme si elle a fait un
copier coller de comment je me sentais
au début de ma carrière qui l'avait
colis aujourd'hui et ça peut marcher
dessus
ça a pris du temps bien madani c'était
comme un terrain complètement de ce père
en fait je m'en suis aperçu quand j'ai
fait les oliviers j'allais présenter un
prix pour capsules radio show patrick
jarry diogo j'ai même voté pour ce texte
c'est juste dire alors là prochain
martin binbin nerveux qui ont institué
comme backstage depuis ce temps moi elle
est présentée de brive hockey pat je
reste j'avais déjà mon bac de préparer
nos pourtant j'arrive au micro pierre
vous allez comprendre et pourquoi pas le
meilleur gagne et juste derrière le camp
ils m'ont annoncé je te peu nerveux pas
tout j'ai eu comme une excitation tu es
là j'avais ma ligne entre est parfait le
sas sas lève ta fardeau mais là j'avais
hipsheim
tout le monde se lève de bouger comme st
mais je sais pas pourquoi je sais pas
pourquoi
enfin que le son but never moi j'ai ma
ligne si la cour dise le facteur par
action votre belle
je prends trop quoi faire mais ce qu'il
fallait face et donner l'impression que
j'avais envie d'aller aux toilettes
mais à 15 heures je faisais comme si
notre monde est beau le cas ils sont
faciles j'ai compris qu'il me faisait un
stage standing-ovation pour tout ce qui
m'était arrivé dernièrement la les a vus
sur ta la fin puis le lien ma maladie je
suis fait avoir sur une scène de revoir
le sou fait que et malignes c'était bon
face au but par un petit problème de
diary alors les nominés ça mais tu
t'apprêtes à minorer cheveux je ne peux
changer ce baiser merci beaucoup
pourquoi j'ai fait semblant d'avoir
envie d'aller aux toilettes je savais
que ça se battaient dans ma taille merci
procès oui
non c'est pas ça alors c'est vraiment
quelque chose
les prix ça fait trois minutes que je
sais que je la voulais aller chez moi je
répète ma ligne je n'ai pas clip non
c'est en quelle année puis les elvis
tank et un bain l'eau sa montagne autres
aux olivier py valeur vous le 4 5 1
quand on refait le numéro du bateau
hathaway avant de leur fatah mais tout
de même très que tu avais dans le teint
rouge et et ouais ouais j'ai failli pour
monter sur cet acte est un papa inquiète
les choses qui quittent les jantes hamon
pour qui la dernière fois que la montée
sur scène avant ça ça s'est mal fini
je m'appelle jean des crimes finalement
à ce tarif on sent toutefois l'eau ça
c'est parce qu'un gars me dire et j'en
apprends qui se passe de quadpack arrête
puis effectivement et ses pensées de
quoi être pas correct qu'il fallu que
j'aille sur scène 0 gens ok c'était un
mauvais départ j'ai pas attendu que
lectra carrière donc on va la refaire
enfin je vais ressortir fait comme si
rien ne s'était passé
mais j'étais nerveux le jeu je leur
parlais avec micro d'un email
et puis ce qui fait que quand j'étais
derrière
habituellement jantes en 4-3-2-1 logeant
un mail ya le 4-3-2-1 jamais entendu
j'ai commencé à entendre lipow je fais
cette chute ou sécu et puis c'est là que
je donnerai 60 des bambins ont alors
commencé à songer noonan a fait ce que
je lis refaite mais d'un put enfin ben
tre 12 je voulais j'avais vraiment
besoin de quatre sont propres et et
froid me trouver quelque chose et donc
ça a été ça a été très très très très
difficile puis quand je suis sorti deux
singles j'étais là mais je l'aï fait
pour ma famille basic à mes neveux et
nièces m'ont jamais vu sur cinq et ils
sont toutes montées de moyens pour mener
voir mon nom qui s'installe parce que
quand j'étais sur scène il était tout
statut de dbb a enfin jugé bon je vois
le frère tiens bon les invités et puis
et je les fais tu met à balancer un prêt
mais jamais elle y est arrivée la fin d
une vie c'est pas celle là puis l'année
d'après seul un parent bédard et midi si
l'année passée il ya deux ans je suis
pas bon en date mais je pense qu'il ya
deux ans
il m'a demandé de s'il voulait faire un
numéro avec kev adams en fait qu'un
madame vous voulez faire un numéro avec
mon les français coeur et je bats wye
oak et céphalées j'ai écrit un numéro le
répète et tout ça mais c'était la
première fois que j'écrivais quelque
chose surtout que je tirais pour 2 et à
ça s'est super bien passé pour lui font
nos bottes ont eu des forêts on a eu et
il y avait un rythme d'enfer que je
retrouvais puis j'ai vraiment eu photo
voit le retient mais détendue puis ben
ali à lens a été faite une maudite belle
expérience plus depuis ce temps à l'eau
si j'ai un ennemi mettons le matin petit
matin enfin attendu bon fax et plus la
scène six pieds un non catégorique c'est
comme un bois il ne te dirai que et
kershaw partir en tournée fini ont fait
un nombre au bord du chemin après ça je
vous regarde aller prendre une bière
enfin c'est avec des amis on paye les
hôtels sporadiques comme ça c'est partir
en tournée ça donne une libération de
plus avoir ces malédictions le du trac à
c'est une libération mongole n'y a pas
de monde
pascal mani tu penses que tu y arriveras
plus jamais que ya pas de solution et
puis seront pas ce que j'en parlais avec
un normand brathwaite a lieu deux étés
je pense oui baisse avait été de 2,2
cavada j'allais faire une émission puis
il était là où un armand mais normand ça
ce genre à vous mais des toilettes avant
de monter sur scène
puis j ai parlé de ça j'ai été à sens
unique american way of you back a battu
quand il vient d'avaler la latence elle
était bon que j ai dû proposer ya
quelqu'un qui m'a envoyé quelque chose
1 1 2 qui avait un livre sur jorge luis
et georges aucune parle de mort dans son
lit ah ouais on venait juste beau pays
piteux s'était proposé de jouer dans
bing thomas oui mais tous n'ont pas ça
non plus les lots pour développer le
personnage choquant on y marche comment
il parle quand même un peu un
marionnettes c'est cela et il a fallu a
essayé plusieurs techniques le pouvoir
parce que lui ce qu'ils voulaient faire
s'est tournée star wars et m avec les
autres comédiens même et on saute pour
que lui puisse naître dans la remise par
dessus tout mais on a tout essayé ça
marche pas aujourd'hui c'est facile mais
c'est pas que la la ça marche avec plus
de 20 ans oui mais comme maicon jupp
heynckes mais je m 6 pi et chopin ont
bien moins de mons un pied 6 je faisais
pas la cote rations du bon bah désolé
ils sont pourra pas te parle pas ce que
c'est mais il m'avait dit que j'avais le
rôle mais mais mais j'étais trop petit
ayant pris un autre copain de retard de
fait le développement de ce personnage
ne fermant sa petite ou est ce que est
ce que tu as encore mettant des numéros
ctos roulait tellement de fois
oui je serais tu encore capable de faire
sur un claquement de doigts faudrait que
tu les révisions ben le batteur quand je
l'aï refaite j'avais fait une nouvelle
version qui reçoit une plaque pour tout
le monde je sais pas si tu as la mémoire
physique
j'imagine qu'il y en a certains que je
pourrai refaire il ya lynx est quasiment
impossible
c'est le numéro du bureau le quai sur le
boléro de ravel
ça c'est extrêmement compliqué puis je
sais même pas comment j'ai chaud de
france je les fais taquin françois
pérusse d'ailleurs c'est lui qui a fait
la trame sonore non et mais c'est je
pense un seul numéro que je serais pas
capable de faire le reste
que ce soit la claquette ce soit au
niveau physique la claquette tu veux
mourir après la draft et puisant aussi
le bureau c'est moins puissant et très
compliqué les autres mégalopoles 1
il y avait le golfeur la golf a ramassé
tout comme les samouraïs l'haltérophile
américains surtout des affaires c'était
surtout les numéros qui bande sonore qui
viderait comme ben exigeant physiquement
surtout la claque puis commencer le choc
avec le kent et tuer mais je faisais un
numéro du numéro c'est à dire quelque
chose à claquettes pas près sûrs pendant
une minute
je faisais jouer au gault qui est
essoufflé qu'il n'aide pas à la claque
est
j'en profite et parce qu'il leur fallait
que mon cardio peines pour faire la
suite mais je trouvais que c'était
tellement un bon numéro pour commencer
je joue je l'avais laissée là mais je
pourrais être je pourrais re visionner
mais mes sketches puis parce que l'eau
ce point ce couple j'ai déjà une coupe
de radio comme deux pas de souci c'est
que j'ai un projet avec comedia avec
sylvain parent bédard pour justement
remettre c'est sketch là sur scène avec
d'autres du monde
donc moi je pense que je serais pas
capable de faire un show d'une heure et
demie de mon nom je serais pas capable
fac on prend plusieurs humoristes que je
vais leur montrer comment faire les
sketchs puis on s en sort semble
repartir en tournée je pars en tournée
télé numérique quand cette ville par eux
mêmes
exactement le cmj catalogue à l'esprit
c'est vraiment cool projet ouais parce
que l'éléphante sais que je peux le
faire si je faisais une rhinite stand up
quelque chose à faire par d'autres
personnes cela marchera peut-être mais
là au moins avec son peut se promener
pas mal partout sa sert a par contre
s'il l'a vraiment physique surtout un
besoin maintenant
ben ce qui est un rôle c'était pas tant
le style physique que la quantité parce
que je connais beaucoup de clown de
cirque en nombre n'ont jamais rien écrit
d'autres où ils vont mettre à écrire
quelque chose de nouveau est la falla 4
5 minutes mais un show de deux ans juste
d'humour visuel dans un show that since
d'un mois ça ça se faisait par facteurs
c'est pour ça que j'ai plus j'imagine
tirer mon épingle du jeu moi je compare
toujours soit un peu à g comme fait la
place par le silence c'est un peu comme
quand tu es dans cuisine d'alain coupe
et et légumes qui coûte la tvp remaniée
pulsions de tout d'un coup tu est attiré
par la télé le drama qui se dit pas oui
ben alors alors j'ai eu l'impression que
mon silence a fait du bruit dans la
communauté puis que ça attirait beaucoup
les gens pardon ça attire beaucoup les
gens fait que ça c'est quelque chose qui
m'a beaucoup aidé dans ma carrière
tu parlais je pense qu'ils s'étaient je
pense que c'est à souhaiter que tu dis
que tu es la chance de rencontrer de
ceux qui t'ont influence il oui ou non
mais il le mit sur pet urgent qu'un
l'écouté qui étudient avons rencontré
john kerry oui puis comment ça a été
cette rencontre là parce qu'il ya quand
même parenté ouais quand même pas
rentrer dans ce que tu faisais puisque
jim carrey faisait des grimaces puis des
mouvements un peu comme jeu tantôt d
articuler le mani c'était surtout le
fascia est ce moi j'étais musée parisien
croyance qu'il fait pas de grimaces
comme tel il est à cannes il est capable
d'imiter une phase 1 ce qui fait que
montrer que toutes ces musiques sont
indépendants statut cela c'est vraiment
lui ce n'est qu'en effet james dean qui
fait coacher veut quand il veut écoute
c'est quand il fait le goût de la petite
maison dans près ici moi je l'aï vu live
à los angeles à qui aucun média le magic
club
en quelle année un peu ce que je savais
pas ce qui m'avait vu avant et moi je
faisais on a quinze années le hamon veut
qu à 3,29 qui fait qu'ils aient lui fait
pas encore de films
il venait de faire je pense aux deux
horizons qui vivent des gens de faire
pire de l'espace qui commit dit le fait
que prier pas fait l'aiguillé pas facile
c'est encore le cas des quotidiens film
qui se fait plus ces jours ci et et se
sont fait que may était dans la flight
collège avec les frères wayans puis
montrent unis sont ils un peu comme ça
commence à se plaire dans le magazine
mad max iv et tu connais c'est un
connaissaient déjà des talibans je
connaissais la semaine d'avant qui
viennent faire son show moi j'ai fait
mon choix aucun média ne m'arrête là je
pense la semaine là et celui qui
s'occupait du cavadee de magic light
magic club c'était la sphère de nice
mais re qui était un autre humoriste
américain qui était sur scène j'ai
choisi une nouvelle et des jets
quelqu'un a atteint 1 voyons acteurs
présents des jockeys chaque logement vos
baxter et c'est john kerry et je le
reconnais et je l'avais vu faire un gag
en chine j'avais boyd riche et nous lui
est capable de se disloquer l'épaule
mais il s'est disloqué l'épaule mais la
bo il est comme des pigeons
dieu lui fait des profils moi c'est ça
les regarde physique
c'est vaste
un jour j'ai tellement ri le plus j ai
rappelé de gags love is a way fait le
malheur il dit il te faisons une coupe
de grimaces à michel qu'elle commence à
m'en faire
balsillie a esquissé gamer comme on le
dit lui même je fais des grimaces
compliments même parce que j'ai jamais
vu quelqu'un fin des phases comme pour
moi je fais des grimaces mais trop c'est
hallucinant ce qui est sûr est que tu as
face le hacker george un peu ça a pas
duré longtemps il m'a fait il m'a fait
son personnage du grand brûlent ils vous
disent pouvoir atteindre ce calibre qui
te reproche à son barbecue qui a foi en
baisse c'est drôle mais de là à parler
ch'ti jed lowrie voir partout et les
lots
je décide d'aller le voir le soir même
voir son show et là un autre gang de
jiri pendant quatre jours manifestons
stand-up ta ta ta ta ta ils ont alors
arrêté parce que c'est qu'avec ce que je
fais le tu y joues fait des jo tout
sommet dans ma tête c'est un autre c'est
un non spectacle et maintenant je réside
à mon bon coup et l'ossétie minutes est
d'essayage de se mordre le cou
je te laisse ben voyons ton hosties nice
a relevé ce qu'il fait sont enfin il se
penche paralympiques
tu as vraiment l'impression que je me
rappelle j'étais avec ma blonde les
potes lors n'obtient en tenant un
champion on parlait auprès des deux
autres au blabla efficace et de ce monde
de court
éloge par image plus capable de conduire
je m'arrête je m'endors uci les jumeux
cochant ma blonde après le voleur je
comptais en série je lui parle à 4
jaunes stade georges estele gueule
une décision est malade dans drive c'est
hallucinant putallaz le maire et alain
le tout devient si propice à quelque
chose
c'est hallucinant génie comique peu
après si tu le vois jouer dans des trucs
qui est dramatique puis tous ces bons et
tout ce qui y touche en était qu il ait
vu cac était dans ce film porno c'était
bon ben c'est pas quelque chose c'est
pas le casting du tout facile en ce
moment il est super bon wells fargo qui
est capable potage dirais que roy benoît
liang guanglie a rencontré aussi nom que
j'ai vu en spectacle à montréal
il venait parler de sa série de films
qui avait fait avec ce tower qu'un
réalisateur canadien entre autres
d'ailleurs on me parlait de ses films
mais robben dizaine de conférences - ce
rapport il fait pas autant trimestre 1,4
c'est un fou et lui il était capable de
me faire pleurer ce que john kerry pas
capable d'avoir ils pas capables d'en
faire pleurer j'ai jamais oui
m'attarderai pas tant ça c'est plus la
bonne voie
j'aime carry on aime le voir
complètement péter dawe adventure gold
cdd
une absence mais jaloux est un film mais
ça n'a pas de sens que ce soit un film
qui soit fils ou est-ce que lions du zoo
je sais pas c'était quoi sur le plateau
mais enduit de faire ce que tu veux
j'ai fait savoir à sa personne je ne
sais pas s'il ya déjà existé dans une de
ces séries d'émissions comme soyez
encore le personnage mais sa barbe était
complètement obsolètes parce que quand
ils ont sorti le film 8e pas connu à
montréal il est critique jay z et michel
quand on mange on y met quand même
appareil photo et bien des jaloux chez
moi je connaissais la supercherie
attendait delawari vinh vous en
remettrez poster fait que non je dis que
tu es jaloux dizaine sur eux c'est tu
parce que toi tu aurais aimé ce projet
comme ça à grand déploiement ao grand
écran de de toi mais oui mais ben en
fait on a essayé il ya longtemps en
france 2 fin en 96 de tourner un film
critiqué au début sa pièce les langues
l'histoire du hockey
émile gaudreault et stéphane bourguignon
ont une idée de chine pour moi c'est
l'histoire d'un jeune enfant qui est
complètement fou et ses parents ont peur
pour lui
ils doivent l'enfermer dans une chambre
et parce qu'ils puissent blesser il peut
se faire mal et immature tv où ils se
trouvent des cartoons dijoux fait le
petit goal in our hitler toute sa vie
les parents et ils sortent pas souvent
puisqu'il s'attaque une laisse by melty
girl il est passé toute sa vie dans la
chambre et un jour la fenêtre de sa
chambre
pep il 140 pillu d'après lui le tout le
monde et quand on fait il part à
l'aventuré puis il vit sa vie de carton
parmi dans la main c'était vraiment un
film le fait que le hockey fait le lien
bien pas du tout français où mme lemay
de l'argent est tout heureux de te
téléfilm canada
au total il ya un australien tous âges
eu droit aux prétentions en tête à
retenir que des personnes et oui c'est
ça fait là bon le glaive quand même 34
millions de francs pour faire de
schering et 8 millions de dollars 20 ans
puisqu'elle vient taguer 25 fax épopée
très près de bouger et or du meilleur
réalisateur du film décide de mettre ses
mains dans un scénario au courant mais
ne fait que je dois montréal arrive à
paris tourné monté me pète les bras et
là je lis le scénario à l'hôtel merci
pour toutes la même femme c'est plus
drôle c'est plus pantoute la même à
franges se pose qui sans avoir verso je
suis pris de panique
téléfilm de pub met de l'argent dedans
photo cl on lui on lui en fait non on
est en fait plus à la veille du tournage
des dames à riad en hôtel elle est là la
crise d'angoissé
qu'est-ce qu'on fait que c'est pas le
film se placer gloss données mongole une
robe une merde de films erreur
merde et ça s'appelait au début mon
dessin animé qui est un beau titre avec
bon avec l'écriture de nos deux
québécois qui étaient priés changer ça
et là ça s'est appelée la balade de
titus une petite balade et le après sa
non finalement change le titre ça va
être leur rêve de la carotte le rail de
laquelle elle est un film porno mais
tellement jeu de karaoké appropriation
sexuelle et alors là je capotais noté
puis après ça si tu as plus notre site
que je me rappelle pop ses revenus à
dessin animé parce que la réputation des
autres titres havas mal passé écoute le
film a passé en salle en france le jaune
et le godard rembourser les gens étaient
tellement mauvaises mais tout est l'un
de ces assassinats mais gamarde et c'est
un pan du temps de montréal et qui se
tient il aimerait passer du sort nous
christian larouche et je n'ai rien que
ça larouche de christal films qu'on
salue one se serait déguisé qui n'ont
jamais voulu travailler avec moi après
je le comprends très bien et ça a été
vraiment lyon fait des tests on va le
passer à des enfants puis en plus la
cassette vidéo que j'ai un seul exemple
chez moi non vraiment c'est pas une
question c'est la fin pour elle a fait
retirer mais un coût de 12 et
le film quand ils l'écoutent tu te rends
compte que c'est un off line
ils ont même pas égaliser les couleurs
c'est pas les bons panneaux qui tue
c'est l'image elle et pixellisée s'est
vraiment passé réalisateur et moi qui
étais pas aussi bon que des deux mois je
sais pas je sais pas si j'ai corrigé pas
c'est vraiment le gars est la vedette
fais ce que tu veux
joie mais ce parce que je sais pas quoi
faire la sale rappelant plus joué avec
jean claude dreyfus delicatessen
boucherie jouer avec lui une qui est
vrai mais c'est quand même quelqu'un est
d'attendre puis avait une nouvelle qui
s'appelait natacha lindinger mois et
vous dire ça a merdé il est tout croche
et finalement ça c'est ce qui a mis fin
à ma carrière au cinéma parce que je
devais tourner un film tout après avec
victoria abril qui s'appelait le matou
et
polygame a fait non seulement on a déjà
fait des chutes à penmarch suffit pas
que ça tombe bien on s'était parlé
souvent on téléphone mobile victoria
abril et puis à moi je te connais pas
mais il paraît que tu es un genre de
genre de voyage à lewis et moi j'aime
pas du ray lewis je n'aime pas sa part
damas accuse d'ailleurs et une italienne
qui changera pas de plomb dans les rucks
mais on sait jamais tripatif non
médaille fait monstre hypothèse aurait
été chaud s'arrête bas cachant salut c
moi 2000 et c'est qui ce personnage
c'est un nouveau personnage cirque à
matéri on sait pas c'est quoi c'est pas
si peu par un genre et la sexualité
ambigüe n'ont pas tranché
non la guitare dans une fille à cannes
barbe blanche juge mélanger le monde
pourquoi ce soir qu'à terre est comme ça
et tout ce qu'il dit ça sente sexuelle
et ben bongo
ce don des pratiques des portes
battantes
[Rires]
j'aime c'est des carottes avec la source
je me faisais face à des milices
métamorphose émergents
avoir une bonne métamorphose on va pas
tenir plus longtemps que vous est ce que
les gens vont dans le fond il s'est
quand même comme atv comment tv comme
atv point tv que j'ai un forfait l'ont
été au début de la plate forme de chaque
semaine et du nouveau stock qui arrivent
nous accepter aussi j'imagine les
propositions axées gênait les [ __ ] les
médias pearson excellent lille 1 on
accepte maussade les projets les
légendes nous sommes contactés sur info
à rabat ce coma tv.com commenté wc om à
ce qu'on fait c'est quand ma tv ses
choix merci infiniment c'est un réel
plaisir et un honneur
ça m'a fait plaisir les amis ps merci à
toi merci d'avoir écouté ses podcasts
jusqu'à la fin de ce père que vous avez
apprécié la conversation ça prouve que
vous êtes de réelles fans de
conversation et du sans fil par cas si
l'on vous remercie vraiment beaucoup
si vous voulez voir plus de contenus
plus de conversations sur pétillante que
ça se passe hier sur p tu es a non
seulement on met tous les podcasts en
ligne au moment où est ce qu on les
tourne donc on a beaucoup de semaine
d'avant sur le pétrole mais on fait
aussi des encore moins de filtres qui
sont exclusifs au mmm pétulant nous
aussi quand on parle d'homme nicole et
moi de la conversation qu'ont bien
d'avoir ce qu'on met un peu plus en
profondeur dans certains sujets qu'on
voulait aborder ou qu'on abordés pendant
le podcast donc
allez sur une page de turenne et le lien
vers sa voix dans la description du
podcast qui remercie encore une fois de
nous avons écouté jusqu'à la fonte